[Music]
in going backwards news submitted by 86
Corolla humans are getting dumber and
science doesn't know why I know I think
doesn't know doesn't know i Cho does so
feel so dumb Steve why I love why why
because we're because theater happy see
we depend on our phone I don't know how
to do math we should be smarter I can't
spell anymore cuz my phone just predicts
every word I want to say let me do we
should have been smarter because of this
boat went the other way
what does dumber mean I'll type in
Google sheets and it doesn't
automatically correctly hang on so then
I'll just be like now whatever I missed
it but I misspelled it and then I'll be
like no you have to correct it I used to
be able to semi calculate tips at
restaurants but now that my wife is
basically at my [ __ ] tip calculator I
can't even do it with she's not there
I'm like [ __ ]
so women make you dumber no relying on
something makes you dumber for sure we
used to know how to read maps
I don't know anybody doesn't really
matter you were in the military you
should know how to read a map okay but I
love you please I know I read ways we
talking about Google map yeah I know how
to listen to direction but is it dumb to
be efficient I think efficiency no I
think efficiency causes dumber it's like
how some people they don't want to pick
out their outfits because that uses
brain power and they just like to open
the drawer and like wear the same thing
every day like Steve Jobs did yeah I
like that actually that's efficiency
because he needed to save his brain
power oh my god I'm wasting so much
brick do you know how long it took me to
figure out this Harry Potter dress today
okay I'm gonna who's the tennis girl she
also did that and that didn't work out
for her nebula no thanas finest oh my
god Elizabeth Holmes the girl who spoke
really deeply was blonde and wore black
turtlenecks and she won wash oh she
copied Steve Jobs she's got copy Steve
Jobs but she is like and
that doesn't blink oh yeah
that chick the chick who doesn't blink I
never saw that this real chick yeah who
like duped everyone she and wasn't very
she didn't waste time getting dressed in
the morning and she turned out to be
very stupid yep very smart for a short
amount of time yeah you do to everyone
yeah she duped a lot of people so
Norwegian men have been given tests for
their military service from 1970 to 2009
and they found that the average IQ
scores were actually thinking now in
more recent years can I make a bart job
forgot what we were talking about even I
got some of the ball well they messed up
because they were testing on men I've
seen the bar got that merchants you've
been with them I see I don't even does a
bar job to keep going no no should be
blessed no one got a thing I'm making a
Polliwog apology video you're right
yeah you should know it's funny I like
that one Thanks that was a fart joke I
like that there had been a steady uptick
and average IQ scores known as the Flynn
effect and that lasted for decades but
now in more recent years they're
noticing that it's reversing and so
they're just like oh why so that's
alarming to people cuz to me I'm like
how much smarter do we [ __ ] need to
be I don't think not much our life is so
good did we reach the pinnacle of
smartness and now is like there's
nowhere to go but now we have
refrigerators we got [ __ ] TVs that
are inch thick like cancer and that'd be
cool my feeling really have it yeah we
have it being suppressed like do we need
to be smarter as a race I don't know
what how do you determine IQ is it the
ability to think critically and solve
problems or is it - yes I have I did but
I I don't know if it was reliable
through online all those no I took one a
person in junior high and it's a it's
your ability to solve problems without
having a previous bias so for example
they can't use tractor they can use
terminology that only people growing up
in a certain area would know so they
can't go okay here's this motor part
I never worked on a car before how am I
supposed to understand what a piston
it's like association with shapes and
things basically to see how quickly you
can solve here though is that it's
between a distinction between
crystallized intelligence which is all
the stuff that you've been taught and
remember and fluid intelligence which is
your ability to learn new stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that's what IQ tests
are generally measuring it's trivia
versus people who build things they're
saying that they generally measure
crystallized intelligence more so that's
why schooling the changes in schooling
that D emphasized memorization have been
the driving force in the decline in
scores what is what is crystallized
intelligence it's the stuff that you've
learned that you've been taught and that
you remember and how fast you have
access to it so like let's say if you
learn all of history I guess someone
that is has smart crystallized
intelligence you go like 1492 oh it's
Christopher Columbus all right certain
dates bloom you have quick access to
declarative knowledge yeah we had rhymes
teachers taught us rhymes that's how we
remember it more 292 Chris Christopher
sailed the ocean blue it's like let me
try to read some people out there it's
like it's like spank bank yeah you need
to jerk off and you go you got it in
your it's it's quick ready to go so you
know now that they've been changing the
school system into not having kids
memorize things anymore that's why I was
[ __ ] Common Core math is like oh wait
so what is what does that mean first
what how did we learn what are they
sayin another difference is instead of
knowing just off of the back of like it
in your memory knowing 2+2 before okay
that's no longer being taught it's like
oh you know you have to know like what -
like breaking down each - and knowing
that it sounds like philosophy yeah it's
like so much more complicated like I had
to get Isaac a tutor because I'm like on
[ __ ] know this [ __ ] we learned that's
what I that's what my sister has a
little kid now and she's about to start
have to teach this [ __ ] and she's like
no [ __ ] way yeah the dollars are
complicated because they want them to
know the theory behind why are you
behind it exactly and not just memorize
it sounds cool to me but it's not
sucks okay I mean it does sound cool and
I think that's why they moved in that
direction but if we're talking about
just a queue test here it works against
the IQ test because they are they're
testing you on what you've memorized
which now don't memorize also they
should change the way they do IQ test
exactly two plus two is four and I
learned why because if you put two with
two if they actually change that in the
IQ test where it's more just things that
you're solving without bias yeah it's
more fluid at least the one and this is
back twenty years ago yeah because
they've they figured out there were
cultural biases like they would say do
they or whatever and then certain groups
would be like what is a data so in order
to assess intelligence or IQ all over
the world they have to figure out things
that weren't they didn't have any
cultural bias or anything yeah so it was
just like what patterns and shapes are
what's the next progress progress in
shape or no matter whatever yeah what
dicks what doesn't fit pretty and it's
like three dicks and at it and you're
like hmm which one doesn't fit in this
picture you know you know like
titty-fuck too but yes so they're also
saying that other proposed explanations
as to why these IQ tests have been
declining is unhealthy modern diet
increasingly trashy media and and then
the prevalence of reading this is a
little county isn't it was like turns
out which is like straight-up Teflon and
chemicals like I can't believe our
parents are still alive based on what
they were how is what we're eating worse
than what they're eating yeah what about
the hungry people during the Great
Depression they were not even eating
that's why I always we're so resilient
people don't know man when people like
oh no don't let your kid eat any of that
oh boy I'm like come on
grains I'm not I mean it's my choice I
he would eat them guy give him a grain
free diet
why is that better could you got
successfully advertised to your reached
skinny leashes better instead of Mommy
leashes he's still a puppy and we don't
know how it's gonna be
well yeah I mean feeding on corn and
greens and stuff they die faster really
our dogs live for like 15 like all my
dogs since this leave my hit 10 phantom
corn whatever the [ __ ] can't agree
forever and they're all surviving yeah
they were outdoor dogs - oh my dogs I do
feel Dumber though I feel like when
you're consistently in school and you're
consistently learning things you like
way smarter which is crazy at 22 I feel
I think I knew more 22 I know now I have
a lot of life experience but like I
don't remember I think it's the process
of exercising your brain it keeps you
smart cuz you're constantly like having
to access knowledge but I think once you
start going on cruise control and you
don't really have to critically think
that much I think that's what needing in
reading stuff - cuz I have actually
since doing jakey news for all these
years I feel like my brain has been
exercised more than like straight out of
high school cuz you've been reading and
you got to think about what you're
reading
yeah because straight out high school
like I went to work at a hospital and I
wasn't learning anymore I just learned
my my field and that was it and then I
was just working every single day and
not ya know I read Witter I feel like
that's pretty stimulating that's very
getting into arguments online that's
pretty stimulating yeah I love that [ __ ]
that is brain exercise I don't know cuz
I just don't really fit with the idea of
like so dumb is subjective - right so
unless we're looking at a specific field
and it's like okay you're dumb in this
field yes or whatever because recently
they did a study on EQ which is
emotional intelligence right and a lot
of successful people rate high in this
criteria where previously we thought
people with IQ would be superior in the
work
placing things like that yeah but that
only I guess like consists of like 20
percent of people with high IQ end up
becoming successful whereas people with
high EQ is like a huge rate I don't
remember the dumb people have so much
confidence it's so that's true when
they're delirious I mean yes they can
really get far because there's no Dom
that they don't even have any like guilt
or shame
yeah or negativity yeah it's just all
optimism they're geniuses yeah that's
when it gets really fun oh sure sure
but that's how you get ahead in life
right and you have all these super smart
people that are like in debt and they're
losers and a cap and they're angry and
then they're just yeah smart doesn't
equal success no it does it what I think
a lot of people think that though
because of what IQ was drilled into
people's heads it's like high IQ equals
a lot you have you have a lot of smarts
but then how come nobody took I no one
gave me an IQ test that was like a
standardized test you want to talk SAT
scores yeah I mean like how is IQ the
measure of intelligence but none of us
were given a nice heart to administer
properly you like a one-on-one proctor
person like watching you timing you it's
yet it's hard who gets who decides I
really need an IQ time no idea how did
you get one why did you get so I got in
junior high gan like a [ __ ] ton of
trouble all the time and then but then I
always got like the top score on the
test so like the teacher was like this
guy is weird or something so we need to
figure out what the [ __ ] wrong with
this guy and then so they're like there
was he cheating or like what's happening
and then so they had to give me an IQ
test
what's your IQ at that time it was like
135 is a range like 135 145 what what is
the range like a credit score like where
where do you do doctor range Allah 300
is considered decent
that afternoon area I took a gifted and
talented like a you know when I was like
eight they were like oh let's like see
if she should be in gifted and talented
and I had same thing I was like acting
out in class but I feel like I'm like I
don't know what kind of intelligence
this is where you're like sneaky or
conniving I knew some of the questions
they were gonna ask and gifted and
talented tests so I got in cuz I already
knew what like the right things you know
what that is talented told me that's
what I feel like get to this talented
well high IQ usually means deviant to
because it's just easier you're thinking
about how to cut corners cuz that's
actually smart yeah yeah yeah this week
people like you cheated to get ahead I'm
like yeah they did good for them they
started figured it out
[Music]